guys i'm going to be honest this is a
strange one so you know soja boy
soulja boy and crypto are two words you
don't think you you'd hear together
actually i don't know if soja boy is one
word we're just gonna assume for the
purpose of argument
it's is it soja boy or sojour boy
soja boy and crypto two different words
you just don't expect those to go
together but today
they did for a very s such a dumb reason
guys
2021 is turning out to be the year of
dumb fraud
you got the people flexing on instagram
you got the people caught by the fbi
you you know it's just things are just
getting dumber
and this has to take the cake for one of
the dumbest ways
to be a caught shilling something
okay we got ourselves here soja boy you
know from the song
soja boy i i don't know if anyone still
remembers that from like 2001 or so i
don't know when it was made
anyways you might know him from some of
his more recent endeavors if you're kind
of keeping up
with the boy you know he went into video
games
soju games he's look he's not just a
rapper guys he's a soldier which means
it's a whole franchise it's a whole
brand he had soji games
it lasted from 2018 to 2018 quite an
amazing business
apparently they were trying to sell a
bunch of bootlegged nintendo games
and he got she got shut down
like immediately he said i had to boss
up
i didn't have a choice this is him
talking about basically shutting his
company down
that had lasted for like
seven months or something like that so
okay so sojou boy's been up to a lot of
things but crypto he's gotten into
crypto recently
and he started shilling a bunch of coins
like a lot of influencers that shouldn't
surprise anybody but what did surprise
everybody
is when he tweeted about one of these
coins he forgot to leave out something
he said found an interesting project
safer mars looks moon worthy sfm
pre-sale live now on dx sale
rocket ship and uh he forgot to leave
out something
he goes they raise in 240k if they raise
it after your tweet
you will get 24k
if you guys understand what happened he
copied his email his promo email where
he somebody told him you shilled his
coin will pay you
and he shield it but he copy and pasted
the message and forgot to leave out the
part where they said they were gonna
they would pay him so he accidentally
shield a coin told everyone who's gonna
shill it and how much he was gonna make
if they made the money and then
immediately he deletes it obviously
after he realizes his mistake but here's
the worst part
he then tweets right after that the same
exact tweet
without the fact he's gonna get paid so
he realized he messed up
and goes hey i'm already in in this deep
sometimes you gotta crank that you gotta
you gotta crank that sochi boy huh
is the sec awake right now like these
people are
handing themselves to you basically
going lock me up dude
manipulating kryptos without disclosing
it deleting the tweet
because you accidentally disclosed it
and then reposting the tweet i can't
imagine anything more shameless
yes i'm lying to you my audience by
getting paid and pretending to be
excited about something oh by the way
hey great project super interesting
project by the way the project he's he's
shilling is a scam
the crypto that paid him to do this is
called safer mars and
it is actually not original it is a copy
of this coin safe mars ladies and
gentlemen not to be confused
with safe uranus but safe mars isn't
even original and that itself was a copy
of safe moon and i know what you're
thinking
wow what's next safe star the answer is
yes
now what does it mean when rappers start
pumping krypto well personally
i guess to sum up this video i would
have to say that it means you should be
very careful
obviously just uh sometimes they'll
objectively show you that they're
shilling to you
but also i just think generally it's bad
it's a bad idea to take advice from a
guy who told the world to superman that
hoe
i i don't know is that the guy you want
financial advice from is that who's
doing your 1099 at the end of the year
is that who's doing your taxes
i don't think it should be quite frankly
i think maybe
you should separate the guy you listen
to for rap
and the guy you get your financial
advice from because obviously these
people can be paid
off and he's already looking for new
tokens to shell he just tweeted
right now looking for the best crypto
tokens to get involved in
like he needs more mars and moons to
shell
so uh a hilarious slip up but you can be
sure
that a lot more go unnoticed so
be very careful when your favorite
influencer just starts shilling a coin
and you've never known them to do that
before
especially if it's a scammy coin like
safe or mars take care of yourselves do
your own research thanks for watching
and i'll see you
in the next one